[Music]
foreign
strategies there are people who just
play the same openings every single time
they're basically just saying yeah
um I trust and Trust in my prep I trust
in my strategies that there are others
who try and adjust it more and frankly
like I like both that's a part of
football as well there's some prep you
know potentially what your opponent
could do what kind of your plan going
into the game how you want to attack how
you want to defend how you want to press
football games chess games they're just
being decided by by really avoidable
errors
[Music]
a big part of football I think is like
taking care of your body doing the right
amount of training but also not killing
yourself and you know tiring yourself
out especially during this end part of
the season it's all about recovery and
and just making sure that uh your body
feels as close to 100 once the games
come around I certainly cannot match
that
um if you sleep while the tuition is the
tournament goes goes well because you're
you have less you know worries and such
[Music]
I never really had Heroes there are a
lot of players in both fields that I
admire immensely but one of my favorite
players growing up was Luis Figo I
obviously love watching the you know
kind of the Ronaldo
messy kind of rivalry unfold they've
been so fun to watch for so long I don't
know a ton about the Chess World but
I've definitely just followed magnus's
path he's definitely
top of the list
[Music]
football I mean I'm definitely an
attacking player who just likes to be
creative and likes to put Defenders on
their back foot and just kind of keep
them guessing that's the kind of the
style I like I like to be very
aggressive very very direct towards
school so that's definitely my style in
football it's easy I'm terrible uh chess
I would say
pretty Universal but definitely leaning
towards dispositional rather than than
tactical play the games that I play it's
just about not making that critical
error I guess for me chess is also quite
simple
[Music]
yeah having your own Puma shoot is
pretty special so I'm definitely proud
of it and uh yeah I'm excited for fans
to be able to pick these up the shoes
are really stylish I love the look and
I'm excited for the future and for
people to to experience like Magnus here
are your CP Puma boots here are my
signature shoes I'm gonna wear them out
of here yeah
good stuff